i wish i was in hawaii right now
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
we did it baby
[Music]
oh yeah this is this'll do
all right we've been traveling all day
but we're finally here we're in our
rental house on the island of kauai
just across from the beach we've got so
much planned but it's late i get the
kids to bed i'll see you guys in the
morning
well good morning guys and welcome to
the island of kauai we got here at the
rental property about midnight last
night and we woke up to the serenading
sounds of rooster crows
apparently feral chickens are all over
the island of kauai and this rental
property is no exception and the boys
have been so excited to see all of the
chickens running around
they woke me up this morning
yeah it's nasty that's right here an
interrupting
that's like one of six of them that woke
us up this morning
there's another one down there they're
gonna fight oh they're fighting already
i think the boys are gonna learn what
cockfighting is here in a second
[Music]
look at that scenery this is beautiful
all right guys we're gonna get some
breakfast at the kilauea bakery and
pizza shop they have some amazing
looking pastries
let's do a one of these one of these oh
this stuff smells so good
oh check this out
we've got an almond paste bear claw
we've got a passion fruit danish a mixed
berry danish a mango danish another
mixed berry danish a bacon apple twist
and we got some sort of bacon egg and
cheese pastry pocket thing this looks
amazing and i'm going to put links to
the kilauea bakery this rental property
and any other fun activity or fun place
we go i'm going to try to put
information about it in the video
description so you guys can do this as
well if you're ever on the island of
kauai
these are breakfast straw bullies this
is the sausage egg and hash brown one
the veggie breakfast stromboli oh
oh it's so good
good morning babe
[Music]
that's good isn't it
our bacon cinnamon twist is so good
all right we got purple sweet potato
danish oh the cream cheese has coconut
in it
no come on you get one almond piece beer
claw i might try this little mango thing
right here then you do it luke i want it
yeah coconut mango oh that's good if you
think everything tastes better with
mango flavoring you might like hawaii
this this one this one's amazing that's
amazing
this is so good
well listen now that we've got that
amazing breakfast out of the way let me
give you a little tour of this rental
property it's
amazing check out this front room
oh my goodness awesome kitchen area
there's another lanai in the backyard
a little bit more private
there's a second smaller house on the
property but no one seems to be in there
so not too bad and check out this master
bathroom
oh look at this
and look at the size of that jacuzzi tub
i could swim laps at that thing
but the only thing cooler than the
bathroom is the location
there's the rental property
there's the beach
oh my goodness
look at this
guys this is why we come to kauai oahu
and maui wonderful places but finding a
rental property like this this close to
the beach would be so expensive here in
kauai it's not exactly cheap but it's
doable if you want to come to hawaii and
you don't like crowds and you're on a
budget definitely check out kauai and
the big island of hawaii those are the
two best places to go
yeah look at you
i cannot tell you how excited i am to go
spearfishing and snorkeling i brought
all my gear
i got to get it out
shoot the circle
water's a little chilly but not bad
oh
[Music]
[Music]
oh
[Music]
well i've had a good time snorkeling
with tom and nate but it's starting to
rain pretty serious and the boys want to
go inside so i'm going to grab my spear
and just go out and explore a little bit
oh my gosh i'm so glad i did that
those turtles were huge it was so cool
but i think we should go inside and get
dry and warmed up
how are you guys doing
do you like it snorkeling in there
you ready to go get some lunch
jacob wait why don't you have your shoes
on
get in the car i'm a son i have a gun
we're gonna go get some lunch and
explore the island and this place is
gorgeous
[Music]
also it is infested with feral chickens
we gotta do a chicken count
oh i see a chicken there was about six
over there six over there nine seven
eight nine nine nine chickens
there's numerous 15 15.
look at the right the right there's two
more
seven eighteen okay
[Laughter]
oh there's one
it was crossing the road the chicken was
crossing the road oh my god right there
there's there there's two three
three four five four oh twenty seven
twenty twenty nine twelve over there
all right guys we just did about a
15-minute drive and we saw 62 chickens
in 15 minutes
i saw one on the ground
all right we're going to try chicken in
a barrel barbecue here
what do you recommend what's your
like awesome go-to stuff i think that's
the kids stuff
there's some macaroni salad hawaiian
coleslaw
i've had it
there's a chicken at the table there's
literally a chicken just walked into a
chicken barbecue restaurant
i know where they get their supplied
chicken
[Music]
it's a nice dry rub
all right we got lunch out of the way
and we're here in hanalei on the island
of kauai so we are going to drive around
a little bit and see what there is to
see
and check out a few beaches
oh there was a pig there's two feral
pigs
you know it's our first full day here in
kauai so we're just going around and
checking out all the different beaches
and seeing what there is to see it's a
nice low-key way to get adjusted and
someone recommended we check out this
beach so we're gonna go on a little walk
down here
what do you think cool stuff bud
[Music]
over by the shoes grab your shoes well
there's a cool little beach but we're
just checking things out today so we're
going to keep moving keep exploring
don't put that up there
hold on i see a box of bread fruit on
the side of the road here let's let's
check this out anyone got a dollar on
them i do
check it out guys these are breadfruit
that one feels good
okay
there's the dollar
there's a breadfruit let's see here baby
thanks thanks
check it out there's so many chickens
well we got about an hour and a half of
sunlight left and i just want to get out
in the water some more gotta test out
some gear and just have some fun i mean
we got a rental house on the beach got
to do it right
[Music]
did you have fun yeah
very cold all right let's get you warmed
up let's go get some food all that's
swimming around worked up an appetite
should we go get some dinner
[Music]
all right guys we grabbed some takeout
from the kilauea fish market here and uh
it smells delicious
i got the teriyaki chicken with the
potato salad and rice milly you got uh
ahi wrap all right i got the ahi burrito
or yellowfin tuna we're gonna give this
this oh it's so crazy
oh that is quite the burrito
that looks like generals racist is the
bag of guts
oh general grievous gus
jacob do you like your food yeah that
was nice that's good
well guys it has been an awesome first
day here in hawaii i've got a belly full
of tuna burrito
and we've got to go to bed because i am
exhausted but tomorrow we're starting
this party properly we've got a charter
plan and it's going to be pretty awesome
so
see you guys in the morning
[Music]
well i'm back from the grocery store but
i had strict instructions to go by that
bakery and get more pastries
there you go becca i love it
[Music]
bagel thing
oh there's the lilikoi lemon bar sweet
potato mochi
coconut mango muffin oh my goodness a
mango scone
and i got a little sweet potato pie oh
yeah these are like a mango cheesecake
or something oh
that's so good oh yeah that's good hey
jacob did you like the coconut muffin
yeah
i'm gonna have the same thing next next
time it's delicious the
boys well guys are you ready to go
fishing and whale watching yes yes
we got about a 45 minute drive to our
charter so we're playing a game where to
see who can spot the most chickens
we got team dad and team mom here
tickets there's a rooster
rooster five five to three we're waiting
three three nine
forty
don't drive look for chickens
oh there's another one just walked out
25.
32
33 34.
in case of a tie breaker goats and rats
count
[Music]
106 and 102. man they beat us
all right guys we're here with the la
hella sport fishing and then now willy
willy boat harbor and we're gonna go out
and do some fishing and whale watching
it's a great little combo tour so
everyone in the family gets to do
something fun
it's gonna be great yeah
[Music]
oh guys this is absolutely gorgeous and
the wonderful thing about hawaii is you
don't have to go far from the port to
get into some good fishing you know
you're going 15 minutes out or five
minutes out not an hour or two it makes
things a lot more affordable and it
gives you more time to fish
all right we got some hawaiian snacks do
you like you like lean himui
linghimui dried mango slices
[Music]
a good job is there anything you don't
put lean hi-mui on
flavor we're just looking for a little
fishing spot and there's a humpback
whale over there
are we just fishing for bait here or
anything so he's gonna come down for
bait but we're gonna drop these down and
see if we can catch anything at the
bottom all right we're what about 140
feet or something
oh i can see some color
oh i got a little trigger fish over here
yeah
first fish of the trip
oh tommy
i think i got a lizard fish i gotta hold
him close to the camera
hold on let me get him on yeah he's on
top
all right tom i think that's what oh
nice little mackerel over here i think
we i think this might be some mackerel
oh look at that dribble tommy's coming
through with the bait
there you go man
oh
beautiful bait fish right there
did a nice little drift caught some
mackerel we're gonna reposition the boat
we're gonna try some more
hi
oh look at these john
what are those
blue line snappers
those are invasive right yes
there you go
little trigger family
yeah well i think the big one yeah
all right guys we got a trigger fish
here and this they call them trigger
fish because this little spine will lay
down this little groove here and then it
flips up when it feels threatened they
would go in holes and flip that little
trigger up so that a predator can't pull
them out and they've got a little horn
down here too it's a way to wedge
themselves in the rocks and they've got
really sharp little beak-like teeth
they'll take a piece out of your finger
real easy but they taste good so we're
gonna keep this one
all right babe come on in
it's a drinker fish
yeah that's a nice sized one
all right count a couple fish gonna move
spots try again
jake and nate are out they are just out
look at that all right we're gonna try
the guava butter here
[Music]
becca you want to try a bite with guava
butter
that's still on there oh look at that
you got a little um little snapper
man we are trigger fish kings today hey
look who woke up
there's some more whales we've now seen
three
i wish i could show you but the gopro is
terrible at seeing things far away
[Music]
right there see ya
[Music]
so we got a big rod with one of those
mackerel on it down here
and we're just kind of jigging a little
bit and see if we can't catch a big
bread or like a gray snapper or dooku a
gt or giant trivally also called an ulua
we might see an amberjack all sorts of
fun things
that's a big fish i think you might have
the big fish jake
is that a big fish yeah
goodness a big trigger fish
teeth on that thing
uh monokali right moanacali
moana it's a goat fish all right nate
oh
you are just trigger-happy
well there we go that's another
beautiful fish
oh
oh good job buddy
look at that jake
throw him right in there
whale just jumped crazy high out of the
water
oh there he is
this is something i really wanted to do
there's a lot of fishing charters here
in kauai and a lot of people go out for
tuna and things out in the blue water
but this is one of only two charters i
could find that would take you
re-fishing for native hawaiian species
which is what i really wanted to do and
we just had a ball it's really easy
short fishing trip you could do with the
family and the kids have a good time
i'll put information in the video
description below if you want to do this
too
we're on the way back to the harbor we
can see another whale
they're just all over right in here
[Music]
that is a nice trigger fish jake
cody thank you very much
great time we had a great time i think i
better get going though i just saw my
boy jump in the water over there yeah
jacob out of the water i saw that yeah
you jumped right in
we had a great time with the charter we
made it back to the rental house
unfortunately
this family looks like a bunch of done
lobsters
nice yeah yeah i feel bad for tommy i
put tons of sunscreen on his face my
face is burnt
oh we just been kind of sitting here
relaxing this afternoon
but the boys want to do something so
we're going to go outside with their
flashlights and see what creatures we
can find out here in this jungle around
the house
oh look at that that's so cool
ah hi he's still on peed on it i kind of
told mom
oh look at that
i got one look at the size of these
things
look i have two toads too i have the
biggest and the smallest always bang on
me
oh there's another one
oh oh look he's just babe oh he tried
he's peeing all over oh it's been a fun
day but we are exhausted you guys tired
yeah
i'm gonna put up this camera and i'm
gonna see you guys bright and early
tomorrow morning
when the rooster crows
well good morning guys we woke up to the
sounds of roosters on this beautiful
sunday morning
and uh we're just gonna kind of take it
easy get the kids fed and uh go to
church
but not thin enough
you guys did you have fun at church yeah
best church ever well it is a beautiful
low-key sunday so we're just gonna drive
around a bunch and just kind of see what
there is to see around the island we've
only explored a small portion of it
do you hopefully
the landscape's so amazing and so
different on this side of the island
every one of the hawaiian islands has an
arid side and then a wet rainy side
that's very jungly and lush this is the
arid side of kawaii
okay we made it to the top of the
mountain to the waimea canyon lookout
which is like the grand canyon of hawaii
we're not going to go up to the top
because they want like a five dollar
admissions fee and that's we're cheaping
out so that's that's how we roll
well that was a lovely drive but i think
i'm gonna get changed and start cooking
some dinner
oh
[Music]
so
all right guys
we got fried fish and sesame and peanut
oil we've got some white miso some
japanese curry some ramen noodles kind
of a seared ceviche trigger fish and we
have a little bit of chili water to dip
our fish in
one curry
right who wants lemonade
[Music]
chili water is good isn't it no
i really like fishing in hawaii the fish
are so tasty and they're so
well proportioned but this is not our
last fish meal of the trip if i can have
my way we're gonna do a little spear
fishing tomorrow it's gonna be awesome
come on get up guys get up get up
we're going snorkeling
this is going to take a while i better
put the camera down
breadfruit looks and tastes like a
grapefruit on steroids these things are
huge
there's half of the bread fruit
wow
you know sailors used to die from a
disease called scurvy when you didn't
have enough vitamin c your blood would
turn solid and your teeth would fall out
it was horrible disease and they found
out by eating bread fruit they could
keep from dying of scurvy it's good
we're eating breadfruit because nathan's
got scurvy he just lost a tooth
all right we're at the kiki aola boat
ramp and uh we're gonna go find her
charter
weight belt in there
all right guys we're here with komahana
charters we got captain koa here and
we're doing it all today we're gonna go
up one of the most beautiful coastlines
in the world we go on the nepali coast
we're gonna see some amazing scenery
then we're gonna go and do a little
fishing and for luggy we'll do a little
snorkeling maybe some spear fishing too
it's going to be awesome
oh right there before
we've already seen like five sea turtles
[Music]
oh
that is gorgeous
okay hold on yeah we're gonna get a
little bit closer
when it's calm they'll go in there and
actually swim around
that's really cool
oh
i saw a defending one dolphins one
o'clock there's a pot of dolphins up
ahead we're gonna go check it out
uh
[Music]
hey becca is that cool
see those people camping underneath that
gorgeous waterfall this is the nepali
coast state park and if you want to camp
here you can it's like a 20 permit
but it is an amazing place you can
either do a very extreme hike or you can
have a boat come in and drop you off
one of the coolest things we didn't do
on this trip
that was way cool
go on man you're good at threading the
needle
[Music]
[Music]
are you having a good time
well that right there is the end of the
nepali coast state park
we've gone
almost halfway around the island but
we're gonna head back and on our way
back we're gonna troll some lures and
see if we can't catch some fish
all right if i see anything hit it you
want me to go run up and start cranking
yeah you can
[Music]
give it a crank
oh that's a little cool right look at
that yeah yeah we'll put them to good
use
ookus they're one of the best eating
sashimi right yeah real good white meat
i would like you thank you
look at that that's a great snapper it's
a uku
really delicious fish this is one of the
prime fish for spear fisherman
he's just a little guy but he's legal
and he's tasty
tell me
yeah
this is my kind of sightseeing right
here
this scenery is amazing
[Music]
yeah there tom
i'm dropping
all right
all right
nice jack
high five dove
yeah
oh look at that water look at how clear
that water is
see that yellow see that yellow one i
think he's the leader
because we are doing the smorgasbord
trip today we've done fishing
sightseeing now we're doing some
snorkeling and spear fishing
foreign
uh
hey guys did you have fun yeah
what was the coolest thing you saw uh
turtles yeah lots of turtles
a king coley that big wow i shot a
couple of these roy which are an
invasive fish here in hawaii so
also a tasty fish apparently bo they do
carry sigutera from time to time well
this was absolutely gorgeous but we're
going to go down the coast a little bit
to another spot see what we can see
there
that pretty cool melody
there's a lot of fish right here on this
coastline okay
there's a crash world war ii fighter
plane here
yeah it's flipped upside down with its
landing wheels up it looks awesome
[Music]
do
[Music]
oh that's a beautiful blue parrot fish
or ooh
i really wanted to shoot one of those
should have had three men pachi and a
tiape
but the moray eels decided otherwise
oh
tommy was that so cool seeing that
fighter plane upside down oh yeah
so fiercely independent
guys did you have fun yeah
that was such a cool charter if you guys
want to do this go to coma hana charters
i'll put their website down in the video
description check them out
we're driving back home and we saw a pie
place we got to do that
hello
oh my goodness a homemade mango passion
fruit pie place is called the right
slice
there was about six other pies i really
wanted to try
mango passion fruit
yes
all right guys we're here at mark's
place we're gonna get some dinner
all right i got a yellow fin tuna burger
here oh it's kind of like a crab cake
only with yellowfin tuna it's nice
a little bit of horseradish in there you
like your chicken teriyaki burger
chicken's watching us eat chicken
i like this he's got like a zip to it
that's good so what do you guys think
thumbs up for mark's place yeah yeah
good that was really good we got some
korean chicken musubi here
all right guys we're back at the house
and i have a bunch of fish to clean but
i don't have a filet knife so this is
gonna be interesting
all right that's the uku
[Music]
oh i don't think i'm gonna get my
deposit back okay
it's been a long day i think we deserve
some pie and mochi it's one bit of mochi
all right is the passion fruit mango pie
here
oh that's good it's so good
pie crust and a christmas had a baby
well good morning it is a beautiful day
here in paradise and we're gonna be
making banana macadamia nut pancakes
with a wide variety of tropical syrups
all those smell amazing
[Music]
oh
there we go
guava syrup
coconut syrup lilikoi our passion fruit
syrup kawaii honey macadamia nut butter
and guava butter
it's a
bomber what's your favorite coconut
coconut i think everyone agrees the
coconut's the best one guava's pretty
good it's a close second yeah
well me and ed are gonna go run some
errands we are gonna go get nathan a
hawaiian shirt yeah
i had a little bit of a storm roll in
last night and it's a little overcast
and it's just a perfect day to take it
easy everyone's a little bit spent
because of all the charters we've been
doing but tonight me and becca have a
pretty cool charter plan we're really
excited
all right guys we're at hilo hatties if
you want a hawaiian shirt or hawaiian
souvenirs this is kind of the uh the
local chain store that you can get it at
oh my goodness
that is so cute
i think that will fit
[Music]
i like it yeah i like it
he's so he's so soft his butt comes open
[Music]
i love him so much
hey guys
[Music]
all right let's go get some lunch
all right guys we're going to go to
pink's creamery we're going to try a
hawaiian grilled cheese sandwich among
other things
who wants a chocolate milkshake
it's like peanut brittle but macadamia
nut brittle and a milkshake
form oh thank you
oh this is so cool is that a good is
that good mango
it's actual fresh mango too like it's
cool oh yeah it actually tastes that's
that's that's really good
that smoky claw pork and that sweet
pineapple that's good
all right becca you ready yeah let's do
this all right we're going on a scuba
date we're going night diving last time
i went night diving my sister got
covered in crabs
she screamed a lot
all right guys we are going to be doing
a night dive we're here at kuloa landing
and we're going with sea sport divers
we're going to do two dives
one right before the sunset and one
after
so
[Music]
what do you think becca that was great
there was a lot of turtles in there
well we spent about an hour in the water
now we're taking a break switching out
air tanks rebecca and we're gonna let
the sun set and then we're gonna go out
at night and we're gonna get a dive in
the same spot and see what kind of
critters come out at night
most of us are pretty on one arm
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
all right guys i managed a couple fish
got a nice little goat fish a little
squirrel fish
oh the squirrel fish tastes like trout
and i've never eaten a goat fish but i
hear they are really good especially if
you steam them corbin
thank you so much man as always if you
want to do this too we're going to put
links to c sport divers in our video
description below
becca was that fun that was so fun i
thought it was going to be a lot scarier
than it was it was really comfortable it
was comfortable i wasn't scared either i
it was great let's go see melanie it's
gonna save melanie from our children all
right that's good
well good morning guys it's another day
in paradise and we are gonna do a very
hawaiian breakfast
i think we're gonna make spam and eggs
[Music]
all right everybody
we got a little linghi maui powder here
i don't want oh that stuff was good
ajinoti furikake which is like little
seaweed sprinkles that you put on rice
oh spicy oh i see
tommy's place
please
you guys like breakfast yeah yeah thank
you so much
well we have a lovely low-key day today
we are just going to hang out on the
beach and i am going to work on a little
project i brought along with me i want
to try to build a spear gun from scratch
so
well check it out my spear gun's coming
along quite nicely we've been spending a
couple hours on the beach and having a
good time everyone's getting a little
hungry so i'm gonna go back to the house
and make a little lunch we're gonna make
a hawaiian dish that everyone in our
family loves all right guys we're gonna
have chicken katsu and fried fish for
lunch and funny thing chicken katsu is a
hawaiian twist of a japanese dish which
is a japanese twist on a european dish
so it's gonna be fun we're gonna do this
i love chicken coffee
we got some chicken katsu some fried egg
some cabbage rice
i was gonna make some fried fish too but
i am exhausted and we have a crazy
amount of food so we'll do that we'll do
fish for dinner you guys like the
chickakatsu yes it's so good
that is the most delicious european
japanese hawaiian fusion food out there
i love it now i got some food in me when
you go back here and keep working on my
spear gun well i'm going to try to
finish this speargun project today and
then go take it spearing and catch a
fish cook it up and it's going to be its
own little video so if you want to see
how i built it and all that
check out the video description for a
link to that video
well it took all day but i did it i
built a spear gun from scratch another
beautiful sunset on another beautiful
day
it's nice to just take it easy today
hang around the house and do work on a
project this is something i've wanted to
do for a while but it gave everyone a
chance to slow down a little bit all
right guys well i think it's time to
make some dinner and i'm gonna cook up
some fish
all right got some pog passion orange
guava
from over here
all right we got the almaco jack fried
up we got the goat fish the squirrel
fish uh we got some
and we uku
some sweet chili mayo sauce here which
good with the fried fish but i'm gonna
try the uku
sashimi fur
i don't i like that that's that's yummy
yeah ugu's supposed to be one of the
best sashimis
that is really good
i hear steaming goat fish is the best
way to do it
but i am really tired
sweet and fried them up but i have never
eaten go fish so i'm excited to try this
one tastes okay but the texture is kind
of mushy
yeah it's a funky texture i don't think
i've ever had that with a fish before
i wonder if with the steaming it it
maintains the
texture a little bit better yeah maybe
well guys it is crazy late the kids are
already to bed
and i am getting up very early tomorrow
i will see you guys in the morning
well good morning guys welcome to
another beautiful day here in kauai
we're gonna go catch a fish and do some
gotaku all right guys i'm here with
desmond thane who is not only a great
spear fisherman but a highly regarded
gyotaku artist and if you guys don't
know what gyotaku is it's a japanese art
form involving printing fish onto rice
paper as gil means fish and taku means
like to print on stone
and it's kind of the traditional way of
mounting your fish
for japanese fishermen
and uh this uh desmond here is highly
regarded here in the islands is being
really good at it so we're gonna go out
and poke a fish and do a little gyotaku
yeah all right
first i gotta go squeeze all of this
into a wetsuit
[Music]
so desmond took his jet ski about 45
minutes up the coast and we found the
spot and chopped in and desmond kind of
dove down to look around and i
immediately noticed three things one is
that we were in 72 feet of water which
is deeper than i've ever dosed before
two the desmond is a much better spear
fisherman than i am and three that i
could hear whale songs
but there wasn't much to see down there
so we hop back on the jet ski and
desmond had me drag him behind the jet
ski and he acted as the fish finder so
desmond gives me a signal i jump off the
jet ski and we're in 64 feet of water
it's the deepest i've ever dove
and the way it works it takes me about
30 seconds to swim to the bottom and
then i've got to hide in a crack and try
to get that big uku to get curious and
come close enough to get a shot at
he wasn't close enough but i took a
crack at him anyways
and i was just thrilled to even see him
and dive that deep and i ended up being
down for a minute 36 seconds
i saw the move and i saw the uku there
right there's tons of them down there
i ended up scaring away the uku but this
big school of moose stuck around i ended
up diving about a half a dozen times
onto this big school of moo and each
dive was over 60 feet and around a
minute and a half
and i got a couple shots but they're all
just too far away and finally i had one
of my better dives and i get down and i
keep my cool i got a nice bit of cover
here and i'm hiding behind this coral
and if you just sit still
they'll get curious you can see them
they're kind of swimming over really
casually and you just
kind of let them get closer
and boom i get a spear into one
and then the spear pulls out i needed to
just lunge forward just a foot or two
right before i shot and i would have got
the barbie improper desmond swam after
it and tried to recover the fish
but uh it didn't work out however
he went and showed me how it's done that
guy can stay down for well over two
minutes and he'll get down on these
cracks and just hang out and he ended up
shooting some big move
absolutely gorgeous fish oh cool
i asked desmond what was his like max
depth that he could spearfish at and he
told me like between 120 to 150 feet
underwater
and after watching him all day i believe
it oh he got another fabulous move
eventually the school of move moved off
so i towed desmond behind the jet ski a
little bit more and he tells me there's
an octopus down here in 50 feet of water
and he sees the tiny little bit of an
octopus head sticking out of a crack in
50 feet of water and points to it i dive
down there
and this is what he saw at 50 feet of
water so what you do is you go you poke
it with the tip of your spear and this
gets them angry and they come out and
start gripping onto your hand in the
spear and then you got to wrestle them
out of their hole and it takes a lot of
force i i spent quite a bit of time
wrestling this thing out but once you
get the octopus to the surface this is
where things get weird the way you
humanely euthanize an octopus is you
bite it between the eyes with your teeth
and if you're a rookie like me and don't
know what you're doing the octopus
starts sticking its tentacles up your
nose and in your mouth and you get
suction cups and weird places it gets
weird but i caught my first octopus and
i bit him
these are nice fish man look at this and
look at the crazy teeth on them
these are very good eating fish everyone
likes moo and there's
my octopus
all right so desmond's going to do some
gyotaku on my octopus so i'm gonna go
ahead and leave it with him and then
tomorrow morning we're gonna go ahead
and print this thing and make a gyotaku
art print from it it's gonna be pretty
cool hey desmond thank you so much for
taking me that was an absolute blast i
had so much fun were you hungry yeah
let's go get some ishida market we're
headed uh a little bit further down the
way get some pokeballs all right let's
do it
no
here we'll try this too
oh oh leahey mouise pineapple awesome
all right guys we're gonna try some poke
okay raw fish
thank you
this is the tsunami poke raw fish a
little bit hawaiian
a
seaweed
bit uh tobiko which is a flying fish
eggs
some sesame oil and then they put
just a little bit of brown sugar in
there
all right thanks desmond i'll see you
tomorrow man
oh man i'll tell you what that pokey was
so good but i am exhausted i'm gonna
head home and me and desmond we're gonna
meet up early tomorrow and we're gonna
do the gyotaku and we're gonna make some
art out of those fish
hi
[Music]
i am painting nice my professional
author sister is working on her new
novel if you like victorian era romance
check out m.a nichols
what what time to go cleans the moo
then and then another
see
not too bad for the first time ever
filleting a moo using a kitchen knife i
found at a rental house
well it is an absolutely gorgeous day
and it is good to be back with the
family and hanging out with the boys on
the beach a good day babe
yeah glad you're back though i am glad
to be back
[Music]
oh
today is nathan's birthday
[Music]
seven years old
oh there we go guys the hawaiian
breakfast of champions
so good but yes
well i got to meet up with desmond this
morning and we're going to do a gyotaku
print of the octopus we caught yesterday
after that i'm going to come back and
we're going to celebrate nathan's
birthday
yay
well i love you guys and i will be back
in just a little bit
all right guys i'm back here with
desmond and uh we're gonna be doing some
fish printing or gyotaku we're just
petting some chickens in the meantime
that's what we do
oh you walked out okay
so a lot of people around the islands
will send frozen fish to desmond here he
run over to the airport pick him up
and here's somebody's frozen mahi-mahi
that they caught and they shipped it to
him and he's getting it all prepped and
gonna print it
i really have to worry about the scales
flaking up or anything
a little bit okay
okay
he's making this look easy but let me
tell you it is not you're taking a flat
piece of paper and putting it onto a 3d
object and that how you do that is going
to dramatically change the image getting
the fin that's the attention to detail
right there one two three
that is gorgeous
that's so cool i'll tell you there is a
lot of technique and skill that went
into that after you finish the printing
the fish is still good to eat so we just
clean it up and there you go
if you leave a little ink on there it's
not bad but you want to get most of the
ink off talk to you
look at that there it is look at that
beauty what we're gonna do is kind of
create like this motion like it's in the
water you never want like a right angle
like that because it just doesn't look
normal you can kind of see the webbing
oh yeah yeah yeah and that really makes
it look special oh yeah yeah i know i
know a couple
i'm gonna slowly drop it right there
into it right
there you go my first hawaiian octopus
that is so cool
cute thank you that was so cool i listen
if you guys want to learn more about
this or if you want to purchase some of
his art check out desmond thane's
website i'll put a link in the video
description below he also has an
instagram account i'll put links to that
down there and he's going to take the
taco and he's gonna do some finishing
details on it and i'm gonna pick it up a
little bit later but thanks man thank
you aloha hello
all right guys me and my octopus we're
back at the rental
there you house
all right guys should we go check out
the lighthouse we're gonna go do
something i promised becca we would do
at the beginning of this trip we're
gonna go to the kilauea lighthouse
all right hop on now
i my wife likes lighthouses and fairies
it's a jam
there's a coconut crab on your legs
we wanted to go to the beach but the
waves are pretty crazy today but we
found this sheltered little cove with
some really mellow ways this is gonna be
great
it's a hot day today so the water feels
pretty good and we've got this nice
little beach here kids are gonna play
and i'm gonna see if i can't shoot a
fish with that spear gun i just made
here comes shake watch
you okay nate
i'm okay
yay was that was that an awesome place
to swim
that was pretty cool but i think we
should go home and get some birthday
cake and uh
some barbecue chicken
has been a good birthday nathan yes
i'll tell you what i am hungry all right
for dinner we're gonna have charsu
chicken macaroni salad potato chips
we've got poi for dessert we've got
linghi muy pineapple and i'm gonna cook
up some of those moo fillets and i'm
gonna use a chinese black sauce it's
gonna be really simple and easy very
hawaiian
[Music]
all right we've got hawaiian style
chashu chicken we got hawaii and potato
chips potato salad we got rice and for
the seafood lovers we got we got black
bean sauce and baked moo
how was the fish oh so good oh you want
some more
absolutely becca you liking that cha-chi
chicken it's really good do you wish you
had some fish a little bit please that
fish is pretty easy to make i'm going to
throw some more in the oven
here's the cake for me
phil it looks lovely
happy birthday
[Music]
[Music]
well good morning it is a beautiful
saturday here and melanie's watching the
kids and me and becca are gonna go
snorkly snorkel day
well me and beck are here at tunnels
beach on the northeast part of the
island and we wanted to go and snorkel
through some underwater caves and stuff
that are right over there but we got a
little bit of big surf over there and
there's a couple signs warning people
not to get in the water so
yeah
not gonna happen today but there's a
cave across the parking lot so we're
gonna go check that out
look at these vines
those are crazy
there's probably some enormous spiders
in here they're gonna fall on our faces
this skill is really far back further
further back let's get to the point
where i'm having to hunch over this cave
still goes further back this thing's
huge i'm almost down on all fours so i
think it's time to head back
this is cool
well we got a babysitter so we're not
going home so what we're going to do is
we're going to drive as far down the
road as we can to the end of the island
and see what happens
this is the end of the road it's hyena
state park which is a really popular
place to go hiking and i can see why
it's absolutely gorgeous scenery but uh
apparently they're all booked up you got
to make reservations online and they're
absolutely booked so we're gonna just
head back well melanie's writing and
working on her books and the boys are
playing in the house contently so me and
becca are gonna do a little snorkeling
just right here in the beach in front of
the rental property i'm gonna see if i
can't get a fish
with my homemade spear gun
so
[Music]
so
so
[Music]
uh
that was really cool
[Music]
we're back at the house and uh we're
gonna cook up some laulau pork
and we're gonna cook up those fish that
i shot and
i've got an octopus to deep fry
we got quite the spread here we got the
four little fish i shot with my homemade
spear gun we got panko fried octopus
from the one i caught the other day
we've got linghi muy pineapple some
macaroni salad some black bean sauce
sweet chili sauce we got chili ponzu oh
we got laulau pork over there potato
chips rice and there's some curry in
there
octopus do you want a little octopus
jake yeah anyone want lingahimu
pineapple sure all right guys we're
gonna go ahead and try the poi if you
don't know poi is fermented taro root
and this is like poi mixed with coconut
milk and brown sugar it's gonna be
interesting this has a fun texture
oh it's got a nice smell to it a little
bit of a molasses smell
try that
it stuck to my mouth
let's see with your mouth closed if you
like that okay i like it it's not a
strong flavor if you like the flavor of
molasses i think you like this but it's
really subtle
hey buddy
all right you guys want to go get some
shave ice yeah
yeah let's go get a shave ice it is a
beautiful day
all right guys we're gonna get a jojo
shave eyes here they're all over the
island a little chain place guava lily
koi mango is a tropical breed okay we'll
come back for those two real quick
these things are huge big little little
tacks right yeah
oh that's really good
hawaiian shave ice is so much better
than snow cones it's like
smooth it has ice cream ice cream in it
oh okay hey guys i think let's see this
okay we'll be right back both hands
buddy he needs it
you got some uh something blue on your
face
all right guys it's late we're heading
back to the rental property so we're
gonna stop at l l hawaiian barbecue and
pick up some uh hawaiian to-go food
get some chicken katsu
eels on ride
oh yeah
oh this is the eel on rice
chicken cots
ramen
you have to eat what you order sweetie
oh guys i've got a full belly and it's
late i gotta get to bed but tomorrow is
our last day in kauai we've got a lot of
awesome stuff we want to see
so we got to get to bed i'll see you in
the morning
no we've got a lot of packing and
cleaning to do
uh then we're gonna go drive around see
a little bit more of the island before
we have to leave
we're getting packed and i had to buy an
extra piece of luggage to fit all the
snacks and treats we're bringing back
for friends and family tons of ling
hi-mui strawberry and mango we've got
kawaii cookies macadamia nuts chocolates
guava butter a couple pounds of linghi
mui powder
i feel like a drug smuggler look at all
this stuff
all right guys we're mostly packed and i
have one more thing i need to shove in
our bags
a frozen ooh
and a couple moo fillets i'll put those
all in the pant leg of my my wetsuit
then we're gonna take the pants and
shove it in the top
and then we're gonna zip that up and
take it home really the only part you
have to worry about is before you get on
the plane once you get on the plane the
baggage compartment isn't heated and
gets really cold in there so you'll be
good so as long as it doesn't melt
before we get on the plane we'll be
golden
well it's a beautiful sunday we're all
checked out of the house so uh we're
gonna go to church and then drive around
the island a little bit you guys ready
yeah yeah
i'm not entirely convinced it didn't
have anything
church was a success and uh we all
changed out of our church clothes in the
bathroom and she was gonna see a
waterfall or something yeah yeah yeah
let's go do it
there's a kappa a sacred historic site
up ahead we're gonna pull over 11 12. i
think there's over 30 chickens here in
this one patch of grass
apparently this is the site of the pali
ahu heyahu temple that overlooked the
river there so
we got a waterfall
step on my back that looks way cool
doesn't it yeah
well it's basically the same but
i do not feel bad for you
baby
it was a really rainy day the waterfall
would be insane
you want to play the chicken game again
yes left side versus right side
[Laughter]
all right guys we're driving through
poipu beach which is a lot more
developed and touristy than the places
we've been mostly on this trip but you
know if you like those sort of thing
there's some great uh beaches here
they're just a lot more crowded
but the waves can be pretty rough on
this side of the island in the
wintertime and there's a couple
sheltered beaches that are great for
kids and for getting out even when the
surf's high so it makes them quite
popular
wait how many chickens you guys got
113. dang i'm getting rocked oh look
he's crossing onto our side
he's ours he's ours he's on our side now
these chickens weren't here when we
drove by a few seconds
i got
that was a good one
let me get some dinner here
oh
yeah utensils chopsticks in there okay
okay thank you
chris i think this might be some sort of
shrimp
this looks like oh this is some sort of
soup who got soup yeah you did you have
three meat sticks okay oh i have a meat
stick yes this is just a straight normal
salmin which is kind of like ramen
fish cake and spam and some
onions
ooh there's some sort of dumpling yeah
it's good
oh i like yours yours is really good
you guys like the meat sticks and the
fried wontons yeah yeah those are good
this place is famous for their pie so
she's gonna try to chiffon pie just
pinch off a big piece
is that fabulous
oh my goodness i don't know what it is
it's so good oh okay i gotta try this
oh my goodness that's good
oh like a custard and meringue mix that
might be mango is that mango oh that's
really good
never had a pie like that no that is so
good here we go
i think it's one of the cheaper dinners
you can get here on the island as always
we're gonna put links to all these
different restaurants and charters in
the video description so if you're on
kauai you can do this too
oh
oh
becca was that fun that was so fun do
you guys enjoy hawaii yeah
well listen i hope you guys enjoyed this
video we have done a lot of travel and
adventure videos all over the world and
over the u.s if you guys want to see
more of our travel adventures check out
our travel and adventure playlist i'll
put a link in the video description
below and thanks for watching we put out
new videos every saturday morning so
don't forget to
click subscribe
all right see you guys next saturday
morning if you like this video don't
forget to check out the outdoor boys
youtube channel where we have hundreds
of videos just like this and don't
forget to click subscribe so you can see
other great videos every saturday
morning and hit that bell button you'll
get notifications thanks for watching
[Music]